les médecins d'un hôpital de louiseville
dans l'état du kentucky aux états unis
viennent de réussir l'implantation d'un
premier coeur artificiel entièrement
autonome sur un patient c'est un coeur
en titane et en plastique qui permet aux
malades une complète liberté de
mouvement l'explication benoît thevenet
titane plastique
voici le coeur du 21e siècle il a été
implanté hier sur un patient américain
après 7 heures d'opération ce prototype
permettent aux malades d'être totalement
autonome pendant quelques heures car
avec le coeur artificiel une batterie
rechargeable est implanté dans l'abdomen
un bond en avant par rapport au coeur
artificiel actuellement utilisé ce sont
de grosses machines comme celle ci
auquel le patient est relié nuit et jour
et dont l'utilisation ne peut être que
temporaire
ce que regrettable de remplacement n'a
pas encore fait totalement ses preuves
mais si les essais sont concluants ils
pourraient être implantés de façon
définitive chez des patients souffrant
de graves insuffisances cardiaques et ne
pouvant être greffé en octobre 99 une
équipe allemande avait réussi
l'implantation d'un ventricule gauche
artificielle chez un patient en quelque
sorte un demi coeur qui fonctionnait
déjà sur le même principe